Es war ein bisschen amusierend. Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 45. Es geschehen noch Zeichen und Wunder und die Jingles laufen hier im Kreis. Nach über fünf Monaten Pause geht es jetzt wieder weiter bei Chaosradio Express. Ich muss mich entschuldigen, dass alles so lange gedauert hat, aber ich hatte eine ganze Menge gute Gründe, die manchen von euch vielleicht bekannt sind. Schlimme Geschichten spielen da eine Rolle mit geklauten Equipment und aber auch sehr angenehme private Ereignisse wie auch immer. Tatsache ist, es soll jetzt hier wieder weitergehen und es gibt neues Equipment und es wird neue Gäste geben. Aber um überhaupt erst mal voran zu kommen, dachte ich mir, recycle ich erst mal ein paar Gäste von früher, die immer gern zu sehen sind und ihr werdet schon im Hintergrund Kirche anhören. Elektra, hallo Elektra. Wir hatten schon vor 14 Monaten das Vergnügen, Chaosradio Express 016. Das Thema war Mesh Networking und das Thema soll auch dieses Mal wieder Mesh Networking sein, denn es sind einige Sachen passiert in diesem Bereich, die durchaus berichtenswürdig sind. Und auch bei dir ist ja eine ganze Menge passiert, von dir kommt jetzt ein Buch auf den Markt.
Das ist schon auf dem Markt.
Das ist schon auf dem Markt. Wann ist es erschienen? Anfang August 2007 und es heißt passenderweise Mesh, drahtlose Ad-hoc-Netze und es erschienen bei Open Source Press, ein Verlag, der sich Open Source und vielen Themenfeldern drum herum widmet. In diesem Fall geht es halt vor allem wirklich um den Kern Mesh Networking. Das war ja unser Thema beim letzten Mal und da haben wir versucht, einen weiten Bogen zu spannen über von der Herkunft, ja, Communitys, die es anwenden, der Community und so weiter und wer die Sendung nicht gehört hat, der sei an dieser Stelle schon mal aufgefordert, da noch mal reinzuhören und das Ganze vielleicht als Aufbau zu nehmen. Wir bauen jetzt zwar darauf auf, wollen aber nicht unbedingt alles noch mal in der gleichen Tiefe erläutern, sondern uns im Wesentlichen darauf konzentrieren, was sich seitdem getan hat.
Ja, eine bestimmte Redundanz wird es schon geben.
Genau, weil man will ja auch nicht die Leute vergrenzen und man möchten den notwendigen Hintergrund liefern.
Jetzt erstmal den Player anhalten, die 16. runterladen, die anhören und dann können sie wieder einsteigen.
Vielleicht sollten wir noch mal kurz den Roundup trotzdem machen.
Mesh ist Multi-Point-to-Multi-Point-Networking mit WLAN oder mit Wi-Fi. Normalerweise hat man einen Access-Point, damit verbindet man sich als Client und die ganze Kommunikation läuft über den Access-Point ab. Alternativ dazu gibt es den Ad-hoc-Modus der WLAN-Karten, wo die Karten peer-to-peer, also direkt miteinander kommunizieren können. Also jede Karte kann im Prinzip mit so vielen Geräten gleichzeitig kommunizieren, wie in unmittelbarer Reichweite sind. Man hat natürlich das Problem, dass die Reichweite dieser Geräte recht kurz ist und dem kann man halt entgegenwirken, indem man ein Routing-Protokoll einsetzt, so dass die sich miteinander koordinieren und sich gegeneinander aushandeln. Hier hinter mir ist ein Knoten, den du nicht sehen kannst. Wenn du mit dem kommunizieren möchtest, dann schick mir deine Daten und ich reiche sie dann an den weiter. Das kann man natürlich über einige Hops ausdehnen. Es gibt in der Praxis schon irgendwo ein Limit, also wie oft man diese Wiederholung machen kann, vor allem wenn die WLAN-Karten nur ein Interface haben. Damit kann man relativ große Flächen abdecken zu relativ niedrigen Kosten. Es gibt einige off-the-shelf-Hardware, die man dafür einsetzen kann. Ganz berühmt ist der Linksys WRT54GL.
Genau, jetzt sind wir gleich wieder in die Technik reingehopst. Sie wollten vorher noch mal ein bisschen auf der Metaebene hängenbleiben. Mesh Networking, selbst konfigurierende Netze, das spiegelt ja auch so einen gewissen Autonomiegedanken wieder. Wir sind selber jetzt in der Kontrolle und hängen nicht von irgendeiner Infrastruktur, die uns einen Provider anbietet, an, sondern wir sind sozusagen unser eigener Provider. In dem Moment, wo man halbwegs auf Kollaborationen ausgelegte Gruppe hat, kann man eben solche Netzwerke aufbauen und das eben in der Größenordnung von Stadtteilen und Städten. Ein Beispiel, was wir ja auch letztes Mal schon durchgekaut haben, was an dieser Stelle durchaus noch mal erwähnt werden sollte, ist das Freifunkprojekt. Sicherlich das sichtbarste Projekt in diesem ganzen Mesh-Bereich. Es hat auch viele Nachfolger gefunden. Mir ist jetzt vor allem das Funkfeuer-Projekt in Österreich bekannt. Fallen dir jetzt aus dem Stand noch andere ein?
Freifunk hat sich mittlerweile in weiten Landstrichen dieses Planeten eigentlich als Inbegriff für so selbst organisierende freie Netzwerke eingebürgert. Zum Beispiel in Indien auch. Es gab 2006 die R-Jaldi-Konferenz in Dharam-Sala in Indien, wo viele Leute von der Freifunk-Bewegung auch anwesend waren. Da gibt es den World Summit for Free Information Infrastructures, der sich zum Ziel gesetzt hat, gerade auch weniger entwickelte Regionen dieses Planeten mit Kommunikationstechnologie und Netzwerkkommunikation auszustatten. Und es gibt seit 2004 internationale Meetings. Das erste größere dieser Art hat in Deutschland stattgefunden, in 2004, und in 2006 war es in Indien.
Und nennt sich das dann auch Freifunk, oder was?
Das nennt sich World Summit for Free Information Infrastructures, aber die Freifunker sind halt ein relativ großer Teil, der da mitspielt.
Ja gut, das war auch schon mal meine Wahrnehmung, also nicht nur meine persönliche Wahrnehmung, aber es war auch mal schon meine Wahrnehmung, dass die allgemeine Wahrnehmung so ist, dass man eigentlich unter Freifunk generell schon eigentlich alle Communities zusammenfasst, die sich mit Mesh Networking befassen, auch wenn das ja eigentlich hier in Berlin gestartet ist. Und hier auch immer noch gut läuft, oder?
Ja.
Was hat sich getan so in den letzten zwölf, 14 Monaten?
Also ich würde sagen, das Wachstum, was für mich jetzt sichtbar ist, das ist nicht mehr so stark angestiegen. Das mag aber auch daran liegen, dass diese Mesh-Wolke ist inzwischen so groß geworden, dass wir zum Beispiel die, wir haben eine Mesh-Wolke in der Innenstadt, also so Mitte, Prenzlauer Berg, vor allem Kreuzberg, Neukölln. Und es gibt eine oben, Hohenschönhausen, Weißensee, Marzahn, Hellersdorf. Und die beiden zusammen sind so groß, dass wir vor allem mit dem bestehenden OLSR-Rooting-Protokoll Probleme haben, dass die kleineren Maschinen mit dem Neuberechnen der Routen, also die müssen diese Vernetzung ja durchrechnen, einfach nicht mehr klarkommen. Deswegen ist es so, diese Verbindung wurde schon oft hergestellt. Dann haben aber die Leute gemerkt, wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie eine extrem hohe CPU-Last und deswegen wurde die oft wieder getrennt. Also es ist eigentlich an der Zeit, dass die Technologie sich da weiter verbessert, sodass man eben auch wieder größere Mesh-Wurken aufbauen kann.
Jetzt kommen wir schon mal zu einem Punkt, den wir letztes Mal sehr ausführlich besprochen haben, das OLSR-Protokoll ist ein Protokoll, was in diesen Freifunknetzen gesprochen wird zwischen den einzelnen Maschinen oder einzelnen Rautern, die dort eben für diese Vermeschung, für dieses Gewebe, Mesh heißt ja Mascheknoten, ja viel mehr ein Gewebe, als dass die normalen Netze sind, die eigentlich mehr so mobiles gleichen. Da hat man immer so ein hierarchisches Oben und dann faltet sich das nach unten aus. Und so ein Freifunknetz ist eigentlich wild und anarchisch, versucht aber darin eben dann noch die Struktur zu bekommen. Und das geht eben über dieses OLSR-Protokoll, das du ja mitentwickelt hast. Da ist eine Menge geschehen. Aber was sind denn jetzt die konkreten Probleme, die jetzt dort aufgetaucht sind im Bezug auf die Skalierung?
Ja, das Problem ist, also dieses OLSR ist ein sogenanntes Link-State-Routing-Protokoll. Und zwar wendet es den Link-State-Algorithmus von Etzger W. Dijkstra an. Das war ein niederländischer Mathematiker und der hat halt ein mathematisches Verfahren entwickelt, wie man das Problem des kürzesten Pfades, was man zum Beispiel auch bei einer Routenplanungssoftware lösen muss, am besten bewältigt. Das Problem ist, die Knoten sammeln alle die Verbindungsdaten von sämtlichen anderen Rechnern. Also zum Beispiel irgendwo sitzt ein Rechner in Mitte und der weiß aber, in Hellersdorf ist ein Knoten, der hat sieben Nachbarn. Und jeder einzelne Knoten rechnet immer wieder aus, wie er mit jedem anderen Knoten in diesem Netzwerk, über welchen Pfad er mit dem kommunizieren muss. Das heißt, dieser Graf, der hat Kanten, also diese Verbindungslinien, und mit der Anzahl der Knoten steigt halt in einem potenzierten Maße, steigen dann diese möglichen Variationen, die man durchspielen muss, steigen die an. Das ist mit 20 oder 50 oder auch 100 Knoten noch kein Problem. Aber mit jedem weiteren Knoten steigt dann diese CPU-Lasse, die durch diese Berechnung notwendig wird, immer mehr an. Also es gibt irgendwann Limite, läuft man einfach gegen eine Mauer.
Also um es nochmal kurz zusammenzufassen, eine Eigenschaft von dem OLSR-Protokoll ist, dass eigentlich jeder Teilnehmer des Netzwerks den vollen Überblick über das Netzwerk gewinnen muss, um überhaupt irgendwas irgendwo hinzuschicken, weil er selber entscheidet, wohin er es hinschickt und dazu muss er sich eigentlich über alles eine Vorstellung machen. Nun sind diese Geräte, die das aber normalerweise tun, kleine, billige Plasterauter, die haben wenig Speicher, die haben wenig CPU-Performance und die sind einfach damit dann überlastet.
Die sind damit überlastet, genau. Und wie gesagt, bis zu einer bestimmten Größe, also 100, 200 Knoten ist kein Problem, aber wenn man dann mehr haben will, dann muss man schon wirklich rumtricksen, also zum Beispiel muss man verhindern, dass immer wieder durchgerechnet wird. Also im Moment ist es so, dass die Freifunk-Firmware, glaube ich, nur noch alle neun Sekunden überhaupt quasi ein einmaliges Durchrechnen dieses Graphen, die es im Router auferlegt und da wird es dann schon wieder problematisch, weil in dieser Zeit kann sich wieder was verändern und vor allem dieses Durchrechnen ist dann nicht unbedingt synchronisiert, sondern einer hat es gerade durchgerechnet, der andere rechnet es zufälligerweise erst achtenhalb Sekunden später durch. Selbst wenn die beiden auf der Basis der gleichen Informationen machen, kann es sein, dass der eine sich schon entschieden hat, ich schicke es jetzt aber da lang, wohingegen der andere erst noch das Durchrechnen zu dem anderen Ergebnis kommen muss.
Aber erinnern sich denn diese Netze wirklich so fix? Neun Sekunden klingt da erst mal nicht, macht besonders viel.
Ich meine, es kommt dann unter Umständen halt kurzzeitig zu sogenannten Routing Loops. Also es kann kurzzeitig passieren, dass einfach dein Internet-Treffik, den du schicken willst, einfach in die falsche Richtung geschickt wird, dort irgendwo im Kreis rumläuft und also sich zwischen zwei oder drei Knoten einfach in einem Karussell dreht, so lange bis die Time to Live, also die Pakete haben ja einen Zähler, wo drin steht. Jetzt bin ich aber schon 255 mal weiter gereicht worden, jetzt ist aber auch mal langsam Schluss, weil sonst werde ich hier irgendwie zum Zombie, der hier nur noch rum rennt und solche Probleme können dann durchaus auftreten.
Das sind auch jetzt reale Probleme, die es so gegeben hat, die so beobachtet werden konnten?
Das sind reale Probleme, die es so gegeben hat und wir sind ihm halt immer mehr entgegengewirkt, indem wir das ganze Netz immer statischer gemacht haben, also dass sich immer weniger Veränderungen...
Was ja eigentlich dem Prinzip ein wenig widerspricht.
Ein wenig widerspricht, ja, weil sich halt die Knoten müssen sich nicht unbedingt bewegen, damit sich da was verändert. Es kann auch einfach sein, dass ein Link jetzt gerade gestört ist, weil jetzt kurzzeitig irgendjemand seine Mikrowelle angeschaltet hat, um sich den Kaffee waren zu machen.
Ja, das stimmt. Und ja, was kann man jetzt dagegen tun? Also ich meine, wenn jetzt alles statisch ist, dann ist im Prinzip das Mesh Networking ja kein Mesh Networking mehr im eigentlichen Sinne. Also zumindest ist es nicht, also der dynamische Teil fällt ja weg. Und die Frage ist, wer entscheidet dann über die Struktur?
Es ist halt diese schiere Größe und diese Beschränkung in der Hardware, die dafür verantwortlich sind. Aber es ist halt auch, eigentlich macht das OLSR, ich muss es sagen, obwohl ich selber halt lange daran rumgefrickelt habe, es macht eigentlich mehrere schwere Denkfehler. Also zum Beispiel, wir haben ja gerade gesagt, ein Knoten rechnet den Pfad aus bis nach hinter Hellersdorf, selbst wenn er irgendwo in Kreuzberg sitzt.
Was für die Zuhörer, die nicht aus Berlin sind, ziemlich weit weg.
Genau, das ist so das andere Ende der Stadt. Und dieser Knoten überlegt sich, also da in Hellersdorf gibt es Hans und Hans gibt es an Fritz, Fritz gibt es an Karlchen und so weiter. Aber das hat nichts damit zu tun, was die Pakete dann tatsächlich machen. Er hat es zwar ausgerechnet, er lebt, also dieser Router hat in seiner Datenbank irgendwie die Informationen, die eben sagen, das muss eigentlich so und so laufen, aber die Informationen, die sich über das Netz ausbreiten, die werden geflutet bei Broadcasts und viele davon gehen einfach verloren. Das ist auch ganz gut so, weil die Flut der Informationen, die jeder Router jederzeit produziert und immer wieder auf die Reise schickt, die wird sonst zu massiv, dass die Performance, also die gesamte Netzbandbreite, die überhaupt zur Verfügung steht, eigentlich aufgefressen wird von den Nachrichten, die nur dazu da sind, irgendwie um das Netz zu koordinieren. Und der Denkfehler ist, dass der Router sich das eben überhaupt ausrechnet, weil er kann weder entscheiden, was die anderen mit seinen Paketen machen, weil die Entscheidung trifft jeder für sich.
Und jeder entscheidet auch bei jedem Weiterreichen immer wieder neu?
Wieder neu, ganz genau. Also letztendlich dient dieses ganze Ausrechnen. Eigentlich ist es illusionär. Also das ist okay, so lange es nur zwei, drei Hops sind, da kann man das irgendwie zeitnah updaten, da kann man das zeitnah durchrechnen. Aber über diese größere Entfernung macht es überhaupt keinen Sinn. Und die einzige Entscheidung, die der Knoten treffen kann, nachdem er diesen Riesengrafen durchgerechnet hat, ist, wem meiner unmittelbaren Nachbarn schicke ich das jetzt überhaupt zuerst? Im Extremfall ist es nur ein einziger Knoten.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir das in den letzten Podcasts schon angesprochen haben, aber mich erinnert das auch sehr an die alten Zeiten im Usenet, als die E-Mail-Adressen noch keine Ad hatten, wo man nicht irgendwas an irgendeinem Domain geschickt hat und dann fuchst sich das selber aus, sondern wo die E-Mail mit einem sogenannten Bank Path versehen war, wo man dann Rechner für Rechner mit Ausrufezeichen getrennt hintereinander geschrieben hat, über welchen Weg man denn nun meint, diese E-Mail gehen müsste.
Das ist im Prinzip Source Routing. Es gibt Mesh-Routing-Protokolle, die machen Source-Routing. Aber das ist eben auch absurd. Das wäre dann so, dass dieser Knoten in Kreuzberg dem Pfad wirklich vorgibt bis nach Hellersdorf. Aber in seinem Pfad sind halt Strecken drin, die funktionieren schon gar nicht mehr. Der Knoten existiert nicht mehr oder es ist einfach gerade unpassierbar.
Das ist ungefähr so, als ob jetzt jeder anfangen würde, dem Taxifahrer zu sagen, wo er genau langfahren soll.
Also ein Beispiel, was ich auch in dem Buch verwendet habe, ist, du schickst ein Paket nach Indien und du schreibst letztendlich die Farbe des Fahrers drauf und der Name von den Menschen, der sich dann in irgendeinem kleinen Ort, wo es nicht mal Hausnummern an den Häusern gibt, sich da die Straße vorschreibst, wo er langfahren soll. Es macht also keinen Sinn.
Es macht keinen Sinn, okay. Und ist da was gegen unternommen worden? Also am OLSR-Protokoll wurde doch auch weitergearbeitet, oder?
Na, die Geschichte ist die, dass als ich mich noch sehr viel mit OLSR beschäftigt habe, tat ich das zusammen mit Thomas Lopaczek, ein relativ bekannter Programmierer, würde ich sagen. Und er hat viele Sachen bei OLSR implementiert. Und wir saßen eines Tages bei mir im Garten und haben uns überlegt, verdammt, wir haben immer noch dieses Routing-Loop-Problem. Wir kriegen es einfach gar nicht hin, diese Datenbänke so gut zu synchronisieren, dass da nicht ständig irgendwelche Loops auftreten. Und dann machten wir so ein Brainstorming und Thomas meinte einfach aus so einem, ja, es war einfach so ein freies Brainstorming, er sagte einfach, verdammt, wenn wir diese Topologien-Information nicht synchronisieren können, warum lassen wir die nicht einfach weg? Und dann saßen wir da und keiner sagte ein Wort und er guckte dann so und meinte, naja, gut, vielleicht habe ich jetzt gerade einen dummen Vorschlag gemacht, das sah jetzt aus und ich meinte, halt, Moment mal, das könnte ja eigentlich gehen. Und er meinte, ja, meinst du wirklich? Und hatte so einen zweifelnden Gesichtsausdruck und dann hatte ich irgendwie so eine vage Idee, wenn wir die Knoten bei OLSR, die schicken Hallo-Nachrichten, die sagen lokal, hallo, ich bin da, gibt es auch jemanden in meiner Nachbarschaft, die anderen sagen auch hallo, und so finden die sich gegenseitig. Und meine Idee war, wir nehmen diese Hallo-Nachrichten und wir benutzen die, um die über das Netz zu fluten. Also die werden nicht nur lokal verschickt, sondern mein Nachbar sieht, ah, Elektra hat ein Hallo geschickt, dann wiederhole ich das mal, dann hören die hinter mir auch. Die Grundidee war einfach nur, wir fluten das Netz mit Hallos. Und ein Knoten, der irgendwo weiter entfernt ist, der sieht einfach, ah, mein Nachbar reicht mir ein Hallo weiter, was von irgendwo kommt. Aber da das den Pfad, also den Weg zu mir gefunden hat, gibt es auch einen Weg, der wieder zurückführen muss, solange die Funkstrecken dazwischen alle in beide Richtungen funktionieren. Und ohne da Topologieinformationen zu verschicken, ohne da irgendwelche Pfade auszurechnen, kann ich ermitteln, wem meiner Nachbarn muss ich das Paket anvertrauen. Und ich muss dazu eben, wie gesagt, keine Grafen durchrechnen. Und da jeder irgendwie das dann an den schickt, von dem er es bekommen hat, treten da auch keine Loops auf.
Okay, ich glaube, das müssen wir noch mal ein bisschen, das klingt nämlich so radikal einfach, dass es wahrscheinlich erst mal gar nicht so einfach zu verdauen ist. Also im alten OLSR hat, ich meine, wenn ich da als einzelner Rechner erst mal eintrete in dieses Netz, dann kenne ich ja die ganze Topologie eigentlich auch nicht.
Ja, aber du bekommst sehr schnell solche Topologie-Informationspakete geschickt, wo dann eben diese große, größere Ausschnitte aus diesen Topologiedaten in einem Paket mitgeschickt werden.
Und der schickt mir wer?
Die werden geflutet über das Netzwerk. Also Topologiedaten werden, so wie wir das mit den Hellos jetzt, also bei dem Batman-Rooting-Protokoll, was ich jetzt angefangen habe.
Aber einer muss ja erst mal anfangen. Also ich schicke im Prinzip Topologie-Informationen, insofern, wen ich sehe.
Genau, die Topologie-Information ist einfach, du hast herausgefunden, hier ist Tim, ich habe drei Nachbarn.
Und dann schicke ich diese Information als solche?
In einen Broadcast und die anderen empfangen, aha, Tim hat drei Nachbarn und dann wird einfach über das ganze Netz geflutet, dass Tim drei Nachbarn hat.
Und alle schreiben sich auf, wer welche Nachbarn hat und welche Nachbarn die Nachbarn haben. Und jeder repliziert im Prinzip dieselbe Tätigkeit, indem er einfach ausrechnet, was Sache ist. Ist das nicht auch der Fall, dass jemand das falsch ausrechnet?
Klar, wenn die CPU-Last bei 99,999 Prozent liegt, also wenn Top dir auf deinem Linux anzeigt, irgendwie hier ist nur noch 99,9, das heißt, da ist nichts mehr zur Verfügung. Der Rechner kommt jetzt mit dem, was er machen soll, überhaupt nicht mehr nach. Also, dass dann irgendwie nur noch arbiträre Ergebnisse dabei rauskommen können, steht zu befürchten.
Okay, also um diese ganze CPU-Last und die redundante Information wegzulassen, habt ihr ja im Prinzip beschlossen, okay, dann lassen wir einfach alles weg und reduzieren das eigentlich nur noch auf dieses mich gibt es.
Mich gibt es?
Hallo Welt, ich bin da.
Ich existiere, genau.
Schön, dass wir darüber gesprochen haben. Und jeder, der so etwas empfängt, sendet es dann wieder aus.
Der weiß erst mal, dass du existierst.
Er weiß auch, ob er es direkt von mir bekommen hat?
Genau, das sieht er dann direkt, dass die Absenderadresse mit der Originator-Adresse, also wir nennen diese Nachrichten nicht Hello Nachrichten, sondern Originator-Nachrichten, dass die Originator tatsächlich wirklich vom Originator stammt oder halt von einem anderen, der diese Originator-Nachricht wiederholt. Und diese Wiederholungen, diese Re-Broadcast, die geschehen halt nach bestimmten Regeln, die verhindern, dass die Sache irgendwie dann doch irgendwie durch irgendwelche Missverständnisse anfängt zu loopen.
Ja, vor allem, wenn jetzt irgendwie alle den Originator von allen wiederholt, dann multipliziert sich das ja natürlich auch massiv.
Ja, ich meine, das erste, was ich gesagt habe, als ich dann gesagt habe, hm, also dieser Vorschlag, da meinten Leute, ja, das ist ja so radikal einfach, aber das kann doch gar nicht funktionieren, so einfach. Das war das erste. Und das zweite war, das skaliert doch gar nicht. Bloß die Idee zu diesem Protokoll, die wurde daraus geboren, aus den Problemen von einem drahtlosen Netzwerk. Und ein drahtloses Netzwerk ist einfach komplett, wie sagt man, hazy, ja. Das ist alles nur verschwommen. Du kannst nicht drauf bauen, dass eine Information dir die Mitte halt, hey, da hinten funktioniert die Route nicht, dass die rechtzeitig bei dir ankommt. Die kann ja hundertmal verloren gehen oder tausendmal verloren gehen. Und du kannst in dem Glauben, weiter routen, ja, da geht doch alles. Ich habe doch gar keine Nachricht gekriegt, dass da nichts mehr geht. Also du kannst dich nicht darauf verlassen, dass irgendwelche Informationen kommen. Und also das Grundprinzip von Batman ist, es gibt Routing-Protokolle, die berechnen Routen. Es gibt Routing-Protokolle, die suchen Routen on Demand, das sind diese reaktiven Protokolle, und Batman detektiert Routen, das macht sonst nichts.
Jetzt ist der Stichwort gefallen. Du hast gesagt, Batman, wir haben es noch nicht erläutert, ist der Name eines neuen Protokolls, das sozusagen nach OLSR kommen soll. Bisher war alles OLSR und jetzt ist alles Batman. Was heißt Batman?
Also, better approach to mobile network networking. Man muss dazu sagen, das hört man jetzt nicht. Nach jedem Buchstaben gibt es einen Dot. Aber es ist verzeihlich, wenn man doch Batman sagt, ich habe... Thomas kam mit diesem...
Das könnt ihr uns ja nicht erzählen, dass das nicht von vornherein so gedacht gewesen wäre.
Ja, aber ich hatte dann doch irgendwann Bedenken, dass wir vielleicht mit der Firma Marvel Schwierigkeiten kriegen oder wer auch immer irgendwie das...
Ist aber ein schönes Bild, muss ich sagen. Ja, also so dieser Retter vom urbanen Stadtteil, der irgendwie flatter, flatter, flatter jederzeit irgendwo auftauchen kann und so ein bisschen als Schutzheiliger, der...
Was uns auch wunderbar gefallen hat, ist so, wir haben ja sehr viele Kirchen. Also wir haben jetzt in Berlin vier Kirchen, auf denen diese Freifunknoten stehen. Also die verrückte Installation ist die Irmaus-Kirche in Kreuzberg auf dem Lausitzer Platz. Da sind acht Router. Der Kirchturm hat acht Ecken und an jeder Ecke steht ein BRT. Und natürlich die Vorstellung, dass da eine Fledermaus, ein Bett, da drum rumflattert bei Nacht. Passt ja doch irgendwie ganz gut.
Ja, BRT, ich zeige es gleich nochmal dazu, das bezeichnet immer den linksten, das BRT-Router. Das ist natürlich vielen bekannt, aber nicht unbedingt immer allen. Das ist nach wie vor so ein bisschen der Goldstandard unter den Routern jetzt für Mesh Networking, weil in einer Linux-Version nach wie vor ausgeliefert wird. Richtig, ne? Die L-Version gibt es nach wie vor. Und dafür gibt es eben auch diese Freifunk-Firmware, wo man sich das Ding relativ schnell in Betrieb nehmen kann.
Das sind diese blau-dunkelgrauen Kästen von der Firma Linksys. Die gibt es schon recht lange. Und die ersten Exemplare wurden mit Linux ausgeliefert unter Verletzung der GPL. Die Free Software Foundation hat sich da beschwert und hat Linksys die Quelltexte offen gelegt und hat damit den Weg freigemacht für alternative Firmware-Images, also alternative Betriebssysteme. Das Radikalste davon ist OpenWRT von diesen Distributionen für diesen Router. Und auf Basis von OpenWRT gibt es die Freifunk-Firmware, die speziell präpariert ist mit allen Bells and Whistles, mit allen Schikanen, um Meshware-Smarken relativ leicht aufzubauen.
Und ist in OpenWRT jetzt auch schon... Also ist Batman jetzt auch schon Teil von OpenWRT geworden?
Also wir haben inzwischen nicht bloß Batman, es gibt auch noch Batman Advanced und Batman Experiment. Und dann gibt es noch Batman Saxnet, um die Liste vollständig zu machen und sowohl den Batman Stable Branch als auch den Batman Advanced Branch gibt es bei OpenWRT. Also man kann einfach über... Es gibt dieses Paketmanagementsystem IPKG, also wie wir, Debian DEP. Da kann man einfach sagen, IPKG install Batman und dann hat man das installiert.
Okay, also noch mal zusammenfassen, OpenWRT ist die Linus-Distribution, die in diesem Mesh-Bereich schon immer auch wichtig, also die generell WLAN-Funktionalität bereitstellt, aber eben auch die ganzen Mesh-Sachen. Es kommt jetzt nicht in der Standard-Distribution mit OLSR, mit dem BATMAN, aber es kommt mit OLSR, richtig?
Nein, das tut es auch nicht. Ich meine, OpenWRT, die Entwickler referieren dazu inzwischen als Open Wireless Router Technology, um sich auch ein bisschen dagegen zu wehren, das hat alles nur mit diesen Linksys-Büchsen zu tun. Und im Prinzip kann man mit so einem Router eben alles anstellen. Und das Tolle halt beim OpenWRT ist, andere Firmware-Images, die sind halt, du installierst das Firmware-Image und dann hast du die Software, die halt in diesem Image enthalten ist. Bei OpenWRT wird ein minimales Image installiert und du hast dann immer noch einen Speicherplatz auf dem Flash-Chip, wo du einfach über das Paketmanagementsystem die eigene Pakete zusätzlich installieren kannst. Und die Freifunkfirma ist halt im Prinzip ein schlüsselfertiges Firmware-Image, was halt schon in der Standard-Konfiguration OLSR enthält. Batman ist im Moment noch nicht dabei.
Aber jetzt nochmal zurück zu, wie Batman eigentlich funktioniert. Also wir haben ja jetzt gelernt, OLSR hat da einfach ein Komplexitäts- und Skalierungsproblem. In dem Moment, wo das Netz groß wird, geht einfach nichts mehr. Und im Prinzip hat man einfach gesehen, in so einem Netzwerk lässt sich sowieso nichts voraussagen. Also lassen wir diese ganze Routenberechnung einfach weg. Also zumindest auf der Basis, dass jeder einzelne Teilnehmer über alle anderen Bescheid weist.
Die Entscheidung, die ein Router treffen muss, ist, wem meinen Nachbarn gebe ich das Paket. Also ich muss die Richtung wissen, wem meinen Nachbarn muss ich das anvertrauen, damit es in die richtige Richtung geht. Und mehr kann und brauche ich gar nicht.
Okay, aber wie funktioniert das jetzt genau? Jetzt hast du ja gesagt, okay, jetzt denken wir uns ein Batman-Netz, wo auch alle nur Batman sprechen, so OLSR ist vergessen. Und jetzt sagen alle erstmal Hallo. Und dann hören sich ein paar und ein paar andere hören sich nicht. Und die, die jetzt ein Hallo empfangen oder wie im Original, ich sag jetzt mal einfach mal Hallo, so und die reichen diese Hallo-Information weiter. Und in dem Moment ist auch klar, dass sie weitergereicht wird und kein eigentliches neues Hallo ist. Das heißt, ich empfange Hallos aus erster und aus zweiter oder vielleicht sogar auch aus dritter Hand. Und wie weit wird das jetzt weitergereicht? Das kann jetzt irgendwie so weit gehen, wie es will oder wo ist das los?
Die Hallos werden per Broadcast übertragen, also die Originator-Nachrichten, um jetzt präsiditär zu sein, und da die einfach nur fire and forget gesendet werden und mögen sie nun ankommen oder nicht, es wird nicht nachgefragt, wenn so ein Paket verloren geht, das heißt, es tritt ein sehr hoher Packet-Loss auf. Und auf diesen Pfaden, wo sich diese Hallos ausbreiten, wo die Routen wenig belastet sind und gute Signalrauschabstände haben, also gute Funkqualität haben, da kommt so ein Paket halt auch mit einer sehr großen Wahrscheinlichkeit durch. Wohingegen jetzt, wenn irgendwo in dem Mesh ein Flaschenhals ist, also wo viel Treffik durch muss, wo eigentlich es an allen Ecken und Enden knirscht, da gehen solche Pakete halt potenziell eher verloren. Und dadurch, dass die Pakete eben verloren gehen oder eben durchkommen, kann man anhand der Pakete, die man empfängt, sehen, wie gut ist eigentlich diese Qualität.
Weil jetzt die Checksumme nicht stimmt oder was?
Nee, weil die Pakete kommen, ja genau, natürlich, das Hello-Paket hat eine Checksumme. Wenn die Checksumme nicht stimmt, wird das Paket natürlich verworfen oder es wird überhaupt nicht empfangen, weil es komplett durch Interferenzen oder Rauschen einfach geht.
Okay, aber woran kann ich dann sehen, dass die Empfangsqualität schlecht war?
Wir führen eine Statistik über diese Pakete. Also jeder Knoten merkt sich zum Beispiel die letzten 128 Sequenznummern für jeden Knoten. Also merkt sich, die Sequenznummer 17 habe ich empfangen, 18 nicht, 19 nicht.
Also mit dem Hallo geht sozusagen noch ein C da einher. Ja, hallo das erste Mal, hallo das zweite Mal und so weiter. Und wenn jemand jeden einzelnen bekommt, dann weiß er, alles klar, wir scheinen ja ganz gut miteinander vernetzt zu sein, aber wenn nur der fünfte und der dreizehnte und der neunzwanzigste kommt und der Rest nicht, dann ist das so ein bisschen so hazy.
Genau, ich sehe, von Tim habe ich jetzt über irgendeinen Nachbarn zehn von 128 Pakete bekommen. Das heißt, der Link ist zwar da, Tim existiert, aber die Verbindung ist wahrscheinlich nicht so prall.
Ah, verstehe. Und dann kann man sozusagen nicht nur sehen, wie sie miteinander verbunden sind, sondern man kann sehen, sie sind zwar verbunden, aber es ist jetzt nicht besonders toll. Und wie weiß ich jetzt, wo ich, gut, also wenn ich jetzt zu einem Note kommunizieren möchte, der dann halt irgendwie direkt oder indirekt gesehen wird, dann ist ja klar, wohin, aber wie kommuniziere ich jetzt ins Internet? Also wer sagt mir, wohin ich irgendwas schicken muss, um ins Internet zu kommen?
Ja, also ein Knoten, der ein Gateway anbietet, also der ein Gateway ist, der teilt halt in seinem Originator-Paket, damit das ein Gateway ist.
Okay, das heißt, der sagt einfach, hier gibt es auch Internet?
Genau, also am Anfang haben wir da einfach nur ein Bit dafür verwendet, also für den Link Richtung Internet. Wir sind dann dazu übergangen, wir haben Gateway-Klassen, also ein Gateway kann angeben, was für eine Anbindung habe ich hier überhaupt anzubieten? Habe ich jetzt einfach hier nur eine ISDN-Flatrate oder habe ich hier jetzt eine wahnsinnig schnelle Leitung, die in beide Richtungen sehr schnell funktioniert?
Und auch eine Besonderheit ist, ist die Bandbreite als solche da drin dann enthalten?
Ja, genau, die Bandbreite ist da drin enthalten.
Uplink und Downlink?
Uplink und Downlink. Und ein ganz großes Plus gegenüber dem OLSR ist halt auch, bei OLSR hat man immer das Problem, das OLSR-Netz hat sich entschieden, okay, Gateway Y ist jetzt mein Gateway, also ich werde über Y ins Internet geroutet. Der Gateway macht Network Advanced Translation, das heißt, meine lokale IP ist dem Internet nicht bekannt, also dem Server, mit dem ich kommuniziere. Wenn jetzt das OLSR quasi meinen Internetzugang von Y nach X umschaltet, bricht meine Verbindung, also eine Stateful-Verbindung, bricht dann einfach zusammen. Und dieser Effekt kann sehr, sehr nervtötend sein, also wir haben in Berlin schon relativ viele Gateways, also ich habe, glaube ich, letztes Mal 25 Internet-Gateways gezählt und wenn ich jetzt irgendwo sitze, wo ich zwischen drei oder vier Internet-Gateways sitze, passiert dieses Umschalten sehr häufig. Das liegt schon...
Das heißt, andere Rechner, die meine Pakete weiterleiten, entscheiden, dass ich jetzt...
Genau.
Dass ich jetzt über B und nicht mehr über A gerotet werde und da ist irgendwie die Information über meine Verbindung natürlich nicht vorhanden.
Mit jedem neuen Zwischenhop, der zwischen dir und dem Internet-Gateway liegt, gibt es wieder einen neuen Entscheider, der sich entscheiden kann, mein bevorzugter Internet-Gateway ist aber jetzt hinter diesem Nachbarn.
Aber das ist doch dann bei Batman genauso, oder?
Nein, das ist bei Batman nicht genauso, weil wir die Gateway-Funktionalität über Tunnels gelöst haben. Das heißt, wenn ich ein Gateway-Client bin, handele ich mit dem Gateway einen Tunnel aus, einen UDP-Tunnel und meine Daten werden halt im UDP-Tunnel an diesen Gateway geschickt und egal wie das Mesh dazwischen, zwischen diesen beiden Punkten routet, ich komme immer bei dem gleichen Gateway raus und ich kann als Client entscheiden, ob ich diesen Gateway auch mag. Bei OLSR gibt es oft das Problem, dass jemand oder ein Knoten Internetzugang annonciert, aber der Stecker ist gar nicht in der Dose. Und trotzdem glauben aber alle OLSR-Knoten, hier gibt es ein Internet-Gateway, weil der halt einfach nicht aufhört, irgendwie zu annoncieren, dass er ein Internet-Gateway ist. Wir haben dann bei OLSR versucht, da so ein bisschen drum rumzuruhten, indem wir ja gesagt haben, okay, wir bauen da ein Plug-in, was überprüft, funktioniere ich überhaupt als Gateway und wenn ich selbst nicht mehr das Internet erreichen kann, dann höre ich auch auf, anderen mitzuteilen, dass ich ein Gateway bin. Aber man kann das auch so konfigurieren, dass einfach blindlings immer das annonciert wird und wenn es halt nicht geht, geht es nicht. Und dann sind die Leute um mich rum, die dummerweise mich als Internet-Gateway haben, die haben einfach Pech. Also ich bin ein schwarzes Loch bei mir für sie Kandidaten.
Verstehe. Das heißt, bei Batman kann man unter den zur Verfügung stehenden Gateways, also alle die, wo irgendwie so brauchbare Hallo-Qualitäten bei mir hinkommen, kann ich wählen und kann sagen, ok, alles klar, das ist jetzt hier so mein Lieblingsgateway. Ich nehme vielleicht jetzt auch mal den, der jetzt gerade nicht so gut funktioniert, weil ich weiß, der hat ordentlich Bandbreite. So und der wird auch schon wieder. Und das wird halt sichergestellt, indem ich eigentlich gar nicht ins Internet was schicke, sondern zu diesem Gateway und der reicht es dann weiter. Gibt es denn, mich hat mal interessiert, also NAT, Network Address Translation, ist ja da sozusagen unerlässlich, um so ein Netzwerk zu betreiben. Also es sei denn, man hat jetzt durch irgendeine göttliche Fügung ein öffentlicher IP-Adressen, aber ich glaube, das ist ja relativ selten. Zumal man dann meistens das Problem hat, dass diese Gateways ja auch selber mit dynamischen IP-Adressen arbeiten, irgendwelche DSL-Zugänge und so weiter, die auch ihre Adresse permanent ändern. Also NUT ist sozusagen quasi unerlässlich. Gibt es denn da auch Vorschriften darüber, wie dieses NUT zu funktionieren hat in so einem Batman-Netzwerk?
Nee, also das wird nicht praktiziert. Also die meisten Leute richten ihren Gateway ein, die nehmen den WAT., den berühmten oder einen Buffalo-Route, das ist ein Alternativprodukt, was etwas preiswerter ist, und installieren halt das Freifunk-Gateway-Plugin und richten damit das ein.
Also meine Frage ging in die Richtung, weil man kann ja in so einem Netzwerk wunderbar jetzt an Diensten teilnehmen, d.h. das klassische kleine Server-Modell, wunderbar, ich hab ja meinen Webbrowser, da drüben ist die Webseite, ich klick die an, die Daten kommen, alles prima, alle sind glücklich, so, aber das ist ja dann immer nur die eine Hälfte, man will ja auch…
Voice-over-IP.
Voice-over-IP, das ist schon jetzt eine relativ komplexe Sache, aber ich sag mal einfach nur mal einen Dateiserver von zu Hause anbieten, dass jemand einem was auf den eigenen Server legen kann oder sich von außen auf den eigenen Rechner mit SSH verbinden und so weiter. Also das Problem des Anbietens von Diensten bzw. das Problem von erreichbaren Ports allgemein, auch für Dateiübertragung in Chats zum Beispiel und so weiter, da gibt es ja auf dem Markt zwei Ansätze bekannt, diese Nut-Traversal-Protokolle, wo man mit diesem Nut-Router selber spricht. Wäre das vielleicht eine Idee, das mit in das Protokoll noch mit einzubauen, dass man sagen kann, hallo, ich will hier nicht nur ins Internet, sondern ich möchte auch jetzt mal diesen Port haben.
Also wir verfolgen mit Batman eigentlich so diese typische Unix-Philosophie. Wir bauen ein Tool, was spezialisiert ist und einen Zweck gut erfüllt. Es hat auch Leute gegeben, die mit der Forderung herangetreten sind, zu sagen, sie würden gerne das Protokoll verwenden, um Nachrichten in einem Netz zu fluten. Wir haben gesagt, nein, das ist nicht unser Job. Also ich würde sagen, das ist nicht unser Job. Also wir wollen uns nur darum kümmern, ein möglichst schlankes, gut performendes Tool zu machen, was sich wirklich nur um das Routen kümmert. Und wie dann die Leute letztendlich das NAT bei ihnen auf ihrem Router aufsetzen, das ist eher eine Sache von einem Paket beispielsweise für die Freifunkfirmen. Oder wie die Freifunkfirmen da eingerichtet sind.
Ich frage jetzt, es gibt zum Beispiel, also ich kenne zwei Ansätze. Es gibt einerseits dieses UPNP von Microsoft. Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, wie gut das funktioniert. Manche Router haben das halt implementiert heutzutage. Andere Alternative ist das NAT PMP, was ein bisschen sauberer und einfacher designt ist. Was Apple auf seinen Wireless-Stations zum Beispiel anwendet und dafür auch ein RFC gepostet hat, was sich also relativ leicht implementieren lässt. Aber das funktioniert natürlich nur im Broadcast. Das heißt, man geht immer davon aus, dass der eigene Gateway auch in dem eigenen Netzwerk ist. Das versagt natürlich so jetzt ein bisschen, wo man so ein rautenes Netzwerk dahinter hat.
Dafür müsste man im Prinzip ein Protokoll entwickeln, was speziell für das Fluten von Informationen in Mesh-Netzwerken zuständig ist. Aber diese Funktionalität würde ich ungern wirklich auf das BATMAN draufpropfen. Da würde ich lieber einfach wirklich ein einfaches Fluting-Protokoll entwickeln. Interessant wäre es auch quasi, um so etwas wie Multicast-DNS für Mesh-Netzwerke zu ermöglichen.
So, und jetzt vielleicht noch mal zurück zu BATMAN. Verzeih mir diese kurze NAT-Ausflüge. Ist denn das jetzt schon alles? Also ich meine, haben wir jetzt schon das ganze Protokoll durchgesprochen, alle sagen Hallo und nach einem bestimmten Schema merkt man sich, welche Qualität diese empfangenen Hallos haben und dann geht es los mit dem Rauten?
Ja, ich meine, ich wollte natürlich nur das Prinzip erläutern. So in der Praxis ist es etwas komplizierter. Also die Regel, nach denen ich jetzt tatsächlich dann Pakete von meinem Nachbarn weiterreiche oder ob ich die eben nicht weiterreiche, die sind schon etwas komplexer. Also das ist nicht so, dass jeder jedes Paket weiterreicht. Das würde zum Beispiel auch die Skalierbarkeit reduzieren. Also ich als Batman-Knoten reiche nur bestimmte Pakete weiter. Also zum Beispiel schaue ich, ist dieser Nachbar, von dem ich diese Pakete von diesem entfernten Originator bekomme, ist das wirklich mein bester Router dahin? Ich reiche nur die Pakete weiter, die ich von meinem besten Nachbarn zu dieser Destination irgendwie weiter reichen muss. Also es ist schon ein bisschen komplexer. Aber natürlich, ich mag einfache Dinge. Also so ein Spruch, den ich sehr gut finde, ist von Antoine Saoizubri, xyperebibado, alles menschliche tun geht den Weg vom Primitiven über das Komplizierte zum Einfachen. Und ich hoffe, dass wir mit dem Batman-Protokoll das Einfache schaffen.
Ist das schon fertig, das Protokoll?
Das Protokoll kann man einsetzen, ja.
Gibt es da eine Spezifikation dafür, gibt es da einen RFC dafür?
Ja, wir haben einen RFC-Draft geschrieben, das ist noch nicht ganz fertig. So einen Vor-Up-Release findet man auf der Webseite vom Batman-Projekt. Und zwar ist die URL von dem Batman-Projekt openmesh.net. Dort kann man sich da den aktuellen Batman-Status-Report herunterladen. Wir haben verschiedene Versionen von dem Batman-Algorithmus. Ganz am Anfang, als ich diese Idee hatte und alle Leute gesagt haben, meinst du wirklich, dass das funktioniert? Das ist doch zu einfach. Habe ich gesagt, okay, also ich glaube, dass das funktioniert. Das Gefühl im Bauch sagt, es geht. Und ich wüsste nicht, warum nicht. Aber wir müssen es natürlich ausprobieren. Dann haben wir einfach eine ganz einfache Implementierung gemacht, schnell und dreckig innerhalb von einer Nacht, um zu testen, ob das überhaupt geht. Und da haben wir z.B. vernachlässigt, dass wenn ich Pakete bekomme, das muss ich eigentlich auch überprüfen, ob ich auch da in die Richtung senden kann. Es kann natürlich sein, ich kann dich wunderbar empfangen, aber du empfängst mich überhaupt nicht. Also beispielsweise typische Situationen. Ein Kirchturm, der steht oben im Funknebel. Der hört erst mal 30 Mesh-Stationen und dann aber auch noch sämtliche WLANs aus mehreren Kilometern Umgebung gleichzeitig. Der hört mich dann, wenn ich jetzt irgendwo auf dem Boden bin, einen halben Kilometer Entfernung, der hört mich nicht, aber ich höre ihn wunderbar. Und diese einfache Testimplementierung, der hat das überhaupt nicht überprüft. Wir sind einfach in dem Fall davon ausgegangen, okay, nur um den Algorithmus zu testen, kann das ruhig erst mal ausgehen, dass das alles bidirektional funktioniert in beide Richtungen. Aber natürlich für den Praxisgebrauch kann man das nicht machen. So entstand dann der Algorithmus Mark II, der eben überprüft, wenn ich was sende, höre ich dann meinen Nachbarn meine Nachricht wiederholen. So kann ich feststellen, also ich sage Hallo, höre ich jetzt Tim wiederholen.
Und wenn er mich empfangen hat, dann müsste er ja im Prinzip das auch gleich wieder raus senden und das müsste ich ja dann eigentlich auch hören.
Genau, also wenn es bidirektional ist, das kann sein, es ist unidirektional, du hörst mich, wiederholst mich, aber ich höre nicht, dass du mich wiederholst. Solange ich nicht höre, dass du mich wiederholst, ist der Link zwischen uns eben nicht bidirektional.
Aber kann das Routing dann auch so gehen, dass der Hinweg über den einen Weg und der Rückweg über den anderen Weg geht?
Batman routet asymmetrischer.
Das heißt, wenn wirklich so eine Situation entsteht, wo man durch ein Wunder in die eine Richtung nur senden, in die andere nur empfangen kann, dann kann man trotzdem erreichbar sein.
Wenn es nur in eine Richtung absolut geht, dann kann man den Link nicht verwenden. Also dann könnte man den nur für Broadcasts verwenden. Also für Unicast, wo es keine Acknowledgements gibt. Aber wenn du TCP-Treffel hast, musst du zumindest die Acknowledgements von deinem Nachbarn empfangen. Aber es ist durchaus erträglich, wenn zum Beispiel ich eine 100-prozentige Wahrscheinlichkeit habe, dass du mich hörst, wenn ich sende, und ich kleine Pakete von dir gerade noch empfangen kann. Also wenn du mir quasi die Acknowledgements schickst. Das ist vollkommen ausreichend. Und diese Situation hat man in solchen Mesh-Netzwerken auch.
Aber solche bidirektionalen Links sind eigentlich auch die Regel, oder?
Die Links sind in der Regel bidirektional, aber die können schon auch asymmetrisch sein in dem Sinne, dass 80 Prozent der Pakete in die eine Richtung ankommen, aber halt nur 20 Prozent aus der anderen Richtung.
Gibt es denn eigentlich auch ein Teilprojekt, das sich mit solchen Statistiken mal beschäftigt, das also wirklich so diese Zustandsinformation mal zusammenträgt, dass man eben auch sehen kann, wie gut die Links... Also es gibt ja diese diese Karten schon immer bei Freifunk. Habt ihr sowas bei Batman jetzt auch schon?
Da muss ich dazu sagen, dass bei Batman da das Protokoll nicht wie OLSR den Zustand von dem ganzen Netz erfasst, sondern sich nur darum kümmert, ich habe Nachbarn und wen kann ich über die erreichen und sich noch nicht mal darum schert, wie viel Hops sind denn zwischen meinem Nachbarn und dem eigentlichen Ziel, mussten wir noch einen Visualisierungs-Server aufsetzen. Also wir haben eine Zusatzsoftware, den Batman Visualization Server. Da kann jeder Knoten angeben, ich würde gerne meine lokale Topologie, also das, was wir vorher bei OLSR hatten, dass du sagst, ich bin hier und ich habe drei Nachbarn, diese Daten werden dann zentral an einen Server geschickt, der daraus eben, wie bei OLSR, so einen großen Graphen erzeugen kann.
Ah, verstehe, aber dann macht es halt auch nur noch einer und da...
Dann macht es halt auch nur noch einer...
.gibt es auch nur noch eine Meinung darüber, wie das Netz ist und nicht gleich 100.
Ganz genau. Und den kann man natürlich auch über Ethernet oder über das Internet erreichen, da kann man an einem Server irgendwo, in irgendeinem Rack, bei irgendeinem Provider stehen und der kann dann die gesamte Topologie erfassen.
So, und ist es jetzt so, dass die gesamte Freifunk-Szene begeistert dasteht und sagt hurra, super, jetzt gibt es Batman, alle unsere Probleme sind gelöst, wir schmeißen OLSR weg und werden glücklich?
Also, es ist schwierig. Also zum einen ist das Projekt Batman, dass wir überhaupt angefangen haben, so richtig dran zu coden, das passiert seit März 2006, es ging extrem gut voran. Wir haben vorher kurz das mit dem asymmetrischen Ruten angeschnitten, es gibt schon auch bei diesem Algorithmus so seine Probleme. Also im Moment ist es so, wir sind bei Mark 3, dieses Algorithmus und die jetzige stable Version von Batman, die routet wunderbar, die macht auf jeden Fall keine Routing Loops, aber die Metrik, also bei der Wahl der Routen, bevorzugt diese bestehende stable Version von Batman tendenziell schon Routen zum Senden, die gut beim Empfangen sind. Also ich kriege 80% Pakete, die du sendest und in meine Richtung zu dir sind es aber nur 60%. Da würde Batman trotzdem bevorzugt in deine Richtung senden. Und es würde also asymmetrisch routen, mit der Tendenz, asymmetrisch in die verkehrte Richtung zu routen. Das liegt daran, dass der Algorithmus halt schaut, wo ich was empfange, da schicke ich was hin. Deswegen, wenn ich jetzt jemanden besonders gut empfangen kann, schicke ich tendenziell auch meine Daten eher dahin. Und wir arbeiten gerade an der Weiterentwicklung davon, dass wir wirklich das genau hinkriegen, dass wir wirklich asymmetrisch genau auch in die korrekte Richtung routen. Also, das Batman funktioniert. Es funktioniert sehr gut.
Gibt es Netze, die das jetzt schon anwenden?
Ja, es gibt es, aber vor allem sind es Leute, die jetzt gerade angefangen haben, selber neue Netzwerke aufzubauen. Es ist so, dass wir hier in Berlin, das ist ja eine beinahe unüberschaubare Zahl von Knoten, die nicht von einer zentralen Administrationsgruppe irgendwie administriert werden. Das sind andere Netze vielleicht anders, aber hier in Berlin und in den meisten Freifunknetzen ist es so, es ist halt sehr anarchisch, sehr individuell und die Leute kümmern sich halt selber drum, manche kümmern sich halt überhaupt nicht drum. Man kann also jetzt nicht einfach sagen, so wir legen jetzt einen Hebel um und wir schalten jetzt alle um auf Batman, weil da würde man sehr viele Leute einfach plötzlich ihre Infrastruktur berauben. Deswegen betreiben wir Batman im Parallelbetrieb mit OLSR.
Das geht auch.
Das geht auch. Also wir wollen auch, also ich meine, es ist so ein bisschen wie so ein Wettbewerb, wir wollen einfach so den Shootout mit OLSR einfach gewinnen. Und also was es angeht, dass es keine Routing Loops gibt, haben wir das auf jeden Fall gewonnen. Und bei der Qualität, also der Metriken, also bei der Wahl der Routen, haben wir jetzt, wir sind gerade bei Batman Mk.IV, also was genau diese Asymmetrie in die richtige Richtung lenkt. Und da haben wir schon im Experimental-Branche die ersten Versionen, die funktionieren und damit kann ich nur banal sagen, kann OLSR echt einpacken.
Ich hoffe, das kriegt jetzt nicht einer in den falschen Hals.
Ja doch, ich habe da schon einige Flames gehört. Ich meine, was man den Leuten vielleicht nur ab und zu sagen muss, ist, dass ich das OLSR im Prinzip zum großen Teil zu dem gemacht habe, was es heute ist. Und dass ich im Prinzip mein eigenes Baby bekämpfe. Also es gibt Leute wirklich, die bringen mir Häme entgegen, weil die sagen, du bekämpfst das gute OLSR.
Dabei ist das für dich eigentlich nur Batman 09 gewesen. Ja, Mesh Networking ist ja nicht nur jetzt in der freakigen Szene ein Thema, sondern ist in den letzten Monaten und letzten Jahren auch, hat weite Kreise gezogen. Ich spreche jetzt an das One Laptop per Child, dieses OLPC Projekt, von dem man immer nicht so genau weiß, was man eigentlich von ihm halten soll, weil es eigentlich permanent seine Ziele immer wieder neu definiert. Tatsache ist, es gibt jetzt eine Hardware, von der wohl auszugehen ist, dass sie dann demnächst auch mal ausgeliefert wird. Ende dieses Jahres ist so die aktuelle Schätzung, wenn ich es richtig mitbekommen habe. Dann kommt da so ein Gerät, was für knapp 190 Dollar produziert werden kann und eben weite Teile dieser Welt bevölkern soll. Aber es läuft so, wie sich die Projektverantworten sich das vorstellen. Wir hatten das ja in der letzten Sendung auch schon mal besprochen, du hast ja auch Erfahrungen mit Developing Countries, warst selber in Bangladesch, vielleicht auch noch in anderen Orten, ich weiß nicht genau, aber du hast auf jeden Fall vor Ort Informationen bekommen. Aber ich wollte jetzt erstmal noch kurz bei der Technik bleiben. Auch der OLPC verspricht, Mesh Networking zu haben und dann fragt man sich natürlich, aha, alles klar, welches etablierte System wird denn jetzt hier verwendet und dann liest man, dass dort ein Standard implementiert werden soll namens 802.11s. Was steckt denn dahinter?
Allzu viel weiß ich über 802.11s nicht, da ich kein Mitglied von IEEE bin und da die passende Doku herunterladen kann. Ich habe dieses One Laptop per Child Gerät schon jetzt ein paar Mal in der Hand gehabt. Wir haben auch Batman und OLSR und Batman Advance drauf laufen lassen. Es soll eigentlich 800.11s implementieren und zwar in einem Chipsatz von der Firma Marvel. Die Firma Marvel ist jetzt nicht gerade dafür bekannt, dass sie besonders gut supportete Linux-Chipsätze für WLAN anbietet. Das ist jetzt das erste Mal. Es gibt allerdings jetzt schon im Linux-Körner, gibt es schon irgendeinen, schätze ich mal, recht unausgegorenen Treiber für diesen Marvel-Chipsatz, der in dem OLPC-Laptop drin ist.
Aber Marvel ist ja eigentlich bekannt dafür, dass sie nicht besonders gut dokumentieren. Das sind nur unter NDAs Sachen.
Ja, das hat mich auch ein bisschen gewundert. Eigentlich machen die ja auch eher so close-source und sind da nicht so freundlich, wobei ich denke, das ist ganz klar gegen die Prinzipien, die die Leute oder Necroponte mit dem OLPC-Projekt verfolgt, verstößt und ich vermute mal, dass deswegen auch dieser Treiber existiert. Das Ziel von dem OLPC-Projekt ist halt, dass diese kleinen Computer auch meshen, wenn die eigentlich abgeschaltet sind, also im Standby laufen. Also es gibt dann drei Zustände, also ganz aus, eben diesen Standby-Modus, wo das WLAN aktiv ist und hat eben den vollen Betriebsmodus. Und das heißt, dass die Marvel-WLAN-Karte, die da drin verbaut ist, die übrigens per USB angebunden ist, dass die selbstständig, so lange es ja immer am Strom läuft, selbstständig Mesh macht. Also in Übereinstellung zu diesem Standard von 802FS.
Wobei dieser Standard spricht ja davon, dass es eigentlich erst mal gar nicht so genau festlegt, was zum Einsatz kommen soll. Da ist halt einerseits von diesem Hybrid-Wireless-Mesh-Protokoll die Rede, zu dem es in der Wikipedia noch nicht mal einen Artikel gibt. Und dann, was auf einem AODV basiert.
Atoq On-Demand Distance Vector ist ein reaktives Routing-Protokoll, was an den Akademien stark gehypt wird, weil sich im universitären Rahmen oder in dem wissenschaftlichen Rahmen haben sich die Leute vor allem drüber, die Köpfe heiß gedacht und heiß geredet, wie stark skaliert denn eigentlich nun so ein Mesh-Netzwerk. Und diesen proaktiven Protokollen hat man immer vorgehalten, also dieses OLSR, die skalieren nicht. Da wird ja so viel gerechnet, was auch tatsächlich stimmt. Aber in der Praxis haben diese proaktiven Protokolle den Vorteil, zu funktionieren und tatsächlich brauchbare Ergebnisse zu liefern. Sie skalieren halt nicht unendlich, aber immerhin sie funktionieren, was man, glaube ich, von diesen reaktiven Protokollen nicht so richtig sagen kann, weil...
Wo würdest du da Batman einsortieren?
Batman ist proaktiv, in dem Sinne, dass es proaktiv halt schaut, wer existent ist in meinem Netz. Bei einem rein reaktiven Protokoll läuft der Knoten und der weiß nicht mal, ob überhaupt sowas wie das Netzwerk existiert. Und nur, wenn er weiß, da ist jetzt Knoten XY und dann fragt, hallo, ich würde gern wissen, wie komme ich jetzt zu Knoten XY, erst dann werden die dann tatsächlich aktiv und es wird dann durchgerufen, hallo, kennt jemand Knoten XY? Also jeder, also die Anfrage nach, wie ist der Pfad zu Knoten XY, wird über das Netz geflutet, bis es jemanden erwischt, der entweder Knoten XY ist oder eben vor kurzem mit dem kommuniziert hat und sagen kann, ich weiß da ein Pfad und der schickt dann eben die Antwort an den fragenden Knoten zurück und sagt, hier gibt es den Pfad. Und dann wird in dem Paket, was dann durch das Mesh wieder zurückläuft, wird dann die Route eingetragen, deswegen Source Routing. Das hat aber die, wie wir schon am Anfang beschrieben haben, diese Probleme, dass solche Source Routing Informationen halt in so einem Mesh wirklich eine sehr kurze Halbwertzeit haben und die Route wahrscheinlich schon gar nicht mehr funktioniert. Und dann kommt noch dazu, da nicht proaktiv gemessen wird, wo geht es denn hier lang und wie gut sind denn die Verbindungsqualitäten, wird einfach der Pfad genommen, wo halt zuerst eine Antwort zurückkommt. Das kann natürlich komplett zufällig sein und der Pfad kann überhaupt gar keinen Wert haben.
Okay, jetzt habe ich dich aber eigentlich unterbrochen, als du noch bei diesem AUDV warst. Ich freue jetzt schon wieder meinen kurzen Einwurf. Kannst du den Pfaden jetzt noch mal aufnehmen? Also kurz zusammengefasst, es gibt diesen Standard 802.11s oder es gibt ihn auch nicht, weil eigentlich ist es nach wie vor ein Draft. Der erste, den man mal ausgegoren hat, wurde dann irgendwie verworfen, jetzt kommt der zweite und es ist auch noch nicht klar, wie das weitergeht und eigentlich definiert er erst mal gar nichts.
Also 802.11s ist der Wunsch der Industrie, einen neuen Standard zu schaffen, der Mesh direkt mit der WLAN-Karte ermöglicht, also dein Computer muss sich da nicht darum kümmern, du besturbst deine WLAN-Karte und dann soll alles Sahne sein.
Ist ja eigentlich eine tolle Sache.
Eigentlich eine tolle Sache und ich hatte ja vorher schon Batman Advance erwähnt. Erstmal haben die bescheidene Ziele, die sind relativ hochtrabend gestartet, haben dann erst mal ausgeschrieben, schickt uns mal eure Protokollentwürfe, damit wir endlich mal eins auswählen können. Da kamen dann ganz viel, aber nichts wirklich Ansprechendes, deswegen haben sie sich erst mal darauf geeinigt, wir haben da erst mal so ein Protokoll, wo man keine Informationen drüber findet, irgendwie was eine Mischung aus AODV und OLSR sein soll, genau um genau zu sein, AODV, also Ad Hoc On Demand Distance Vector und dem proaktiven OLSR und zwar nennen sie das jetzt Radio Aware OLSR und zwar kopieren sie im Prinzip das, was wir bei Freifunk machen, wir haben dieses OLSR durch solche Features wie sogenanntes Fischaugenrouting erweitert, um die Skalierbarkeit zu erhöhen. Und all das soll dann da irgendwie implementiert werden, aber Hauptsache erst mal eine Hardware, die irgendwie selber meshfähig ist, das Protokoll, naja vielleicht finden wir ja mal irgendwann eins, was geht, das ist im Prinzip glaube ich der Stand.
Also im Prinzip, wenn ich das richtig verstehe, wenn sie in diesem Stand-by-Modus laufen wollen, bedeutet das ja, dass diese Hardware selber in der Lage ist, dieses Protokoll zu sprechen, unabhängig von der CPU, das heißt man muss in den Stein rein.
Genau.
Und das macht ihr auch, sowas?
Also im Moment haben wir nicht den Stein, aber wir wirfeln die Sachen jetzt relativ viel durcheinander. Wir haben mit dem OLSR und mit dem klassischen Batman, den wir jetzt als Stable haben, routen wir auf IP-Ebene. Also es werden einfach IP-Rooting-Tabellen manipuliert. Aber auf der Hardware-Ebene kann man auf der Mac-Ebene Mesh-Rooting machen. Das heißt, du steckst deine WLAN-Karte rein und dein Knoten ist mit den anderen Mesh-Knoten, auch wenn die über mehrere Hops entfernt sind, link local. So als würdest du deinen Rechner per Ethernet einfach in einen Switch stecken. Das ist natürlich attraktiv, auf eine Art. Weil du kannst jegliches Protokoll, es muss eben nicht nur IP sein, du kannst jegliches Protokoll dafür darüber fahren.
Ah, verstehe. Deswegen hat er auch ein 802.11-Standard, weil er im Prinzip von IP erstmal gar nichts weiß und wissen muss.
Und sie haben aber, wie gesagt, bescheidene Ziele, sie wollen sich beim Routing auf 32 Knoten beschränken. Das Problem ist natürlich auch eben, diese WLAN-Karten sollen ja billig sein und deswegen hat man ja jetzt nicht so die fürstliche Hardware-Ausstattung. Also ich weiß, dass zum Beispiel dieser Marvel-Chip, der hat 96 Kilobyte RAM. Also im Prinzip ist ein kompletter Computer, eigentlich, der über USB angebunden ist, der hat eine eigene CPU, hat ein eigenes Flash, hat ein eigenes RAM und in diese kleine Maschine soll man eben diese Funktionalität quetschen, dass er eben von alleine mescht und WLAN spricht.
Ja, aber das finde ich jetzt einen interessanten Gedanken, weil von daher habe ich das noch gar nicht aufgezogen. Dass man im Prinzip das ganze Mesh-Network als Verlängerung des eigenen Ethernet-Kabels begreift, so wie das ja eigentlich auch bei WLAN ursprünglich mal gedacht war. Man hat so seinen Access-Point und alle, die halt diesen gleichen Access-Point sehen und benutzen, sind wie mit einem Kabel miteinander verbunden. Was natürlich jetzt bei den ersten Freifunknetzen ganz anders war. Da wurde dann halt IP geroutet und auch, wie du vorhin schon gesagt hast, wenn ich halt zu meinem Gateway spreche, dann brauche ich dafür eben ein Tunnelprotokoll, was ja im Prinzip schon mal ein ganz interessanter Ansatz ist, weil so könnte ich ja eigentlich auch mit jedem kommunizieren in diesem Netzwerk, sodass das eben so aussieht, als wäre er tatsächlich in meinem Netz und zur Adressierung brauche ich eigentlich nur diese Hardware-Mega-Adresse.
Ja, das bringt einige Vorteile, bringt sicherlich natürlich auch Nachteile. Also für Batman bringt es das, die Pakete von Batman, die da zum, also die Protokollinformationen sind ohnehin sehr klein. Also ein Batman-Paket ist, wenn es auf IP basiert, irgendwie etwa 52 Byte groß oder wenn es 62, nicht dass ich mich hinterher korrigieren muss. Und eigentlich in so einem WLAN-Frame sind diese Informationen bis auf die Sequenznummer schon drin. Also man kann im Prinzip WLAN-Frames, die eigentlich nur Beacons sind, da sind noch irgendwelche Bytes reserviert, da kann man irgendwie diese ganz kleinen Zusatzinformationen, die das Batman-Protokoll braucht, gleich mit reinpacken. Dann hat man diese Batman-Informationen schon in den Beacons mit drin. Das heißt, man hat einen viel geringeren Overhead und man kann es potenziell eben auch mit der WLAN-Karte machen. Also wer weiß, vielleicht wird Batman irgendwann mal das bevorzugte Protokoll für 802.fs.
Naja, bringt ihr euch denn auch selber ins Gespräch?
Also so, dass wir da aktiv bei der Industrie geworden sind, sind wir nicht. Umgekehrt haben wir so ein bisschen Schärereien. Die Firma Microtik hat sich leider bei unserem Code bedient.
Wie heißt die Firma?
Microtik, das ist eine Firma in Lettland, in Riga. Die bauen, ja, für Wireless Internet Service Provider bauen die Router. Routerplatinen, komplette Router. Die sind relativ bekannt und die haben sich, ja, unser Protokoll genommen, haben gesagt, ja, schöne Dokumentation, schöne Idee. Wir machen da jetzt eine kommerzielle Implementierung von, woraufhin ich meinte, es wäre doch viel besser, wenn ihr mit uns zusammenarbeiten würdet und die Antwort war, zusammenarbeiten? Wozu? Und bei was? Und ich habe dann irgendwann mal, wir von denen, sie haben dann so ein Router-OS, nennen sie das, so ein Betriebssystem, wo sie komplett verschweigen, dass es eigentlich nichts anderes ist als Linux mit so einem Cisco-artigen Baum-Kommandosystem, wo du auf der Kommandozelle dich per Telnet oder SSA einloggst und jeder Befehl eigentlich in so einem Verzeichnis-Baum eingebunden ist. Und da haben wir uns mal, wie gesagt, eine aktuelle Beta-Version runtergeladen und als ich das, ich habe das in QEMO, also in der virtuellen Maschine laufen lassen und dann geguckt, was haben sie an Routing-Protokollen und da stieg ich dann auf das Protokoll Mesh-Made Easy und bei den Konfigurationsparametern kam mir das alles sehr bekannt vor. Und dann haben wir uns mal da das gemountet, also mit Linux und mit LO Setup und mal da reingeschaut und gefunden, dass das Ding, was da in dem Befehlsbaum als Mesh-Made Easy bezeichnet wird, intern BATMAN heißt und auch auf Anfragen von Usern, was denn nun eigentlich dieses Mesh-Made Easy-Protokoll ist, hieß es, naja, das sei ähnlich zu BATMAN. Und wenn man da mal irgendwie durch den Binär-Code greppt, dann findet man unsere kompletten Debugging-Informationen. Also die Zeilen sind eins zu eins da drin, ja?
Und Batman steht aber unter GPL.
Unter GPL, genau.
Und ist da jetzt schon jemand vorstellig geworden?
Das ist so, ich muss gestehen, dass ich irgendwie keine Lust habe, mich eigentlich darum zu kümmern. Wir haben mit Harald Welte, der diese GPL-Valations betreibt, uns mal unterhalten. Und ja, wir können einen Rechtsanwalt beauftragen und der kann denen halt einen nachdrücklichen Brief schreiben. Aber ja, ich weiß nicht, also ich bin relativ zurückhaltend. Ich möchte mich eigentlich eher mit der Entwicklung von Routing-Protokollen beschäftigen, als mich mit solchen juristischen Spiegelfechtereien rumzuschlagen.
Ja, gut, also ich meine, so ganz unerfolgreich war das Projekt GpEvaluations ja nicht. Kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass das sinnvoll ist.
Ja, wir sitzen hier in Deutschland und Microtik hat jetzt keinen offiziellen Importeur. Es gibt zwar einzelne kleine Firmen, kleine Recrouter, die kaufen bei routerboard.com, das ist die Webseite von Microtik, wo sie die Dinge vermarken. Kaufen sie diese Geräte ein und vermarken sie halt auf dem deutschen Markt. Und nur diesen Leuten könnten wir eigentlich auf die Zehen treten.
Ich meine, das ist ja auch bei den ersten Aktivitäten von GP-Ever-Legions nicht sehr viel anders gelaufen. Da waren das auch die deutschen Vertretungen, die halt Technologie verkauft haben, die andere hergestellt haben. Das ist ja letztlich entscheidend.
Ja, ich finde, es ist mir, ja, also ich, es ist mir schon auch peinlich, aber es ist irgendwie...
Ja gut, ich meine, ich kann das gut nachvollziehen. Man möchte sich halt mit dem Scheiß nicht rumschlagen.
Genau, also es ist für mich Kafka's Welt.
Er hat unsere Gespräche gehört und hat Lust und Zeit, da noch mal was zu machen, obwohl er natürlich letztlich als Copyright-Holder dort aktiv werden muss, also schon letztlich als Person da auch dahinter stehen muss. So war es ja bei Harald auch, der in das Projekt gekommen ist, weil er eben selber Code geschrieben hat für Netfilter und da eben dann allen Linux-Herstellern auch ordentlich die Ommel geben konnte, weil er eben da drin steht in dem Source-Code und sagen konnte, das ist ja meins. Wie viele Leute arbeiten denn jetzt gerade mit bei Batman?
Aktive Entwickler haben wir sechs.
Das ist schon eine ganze Menge.
Das ist eine ganze Menge.
Das heißt, da steckt schon ordentlich Power dahinter.
Ja, und die Leute sind nicht nur, dass sie gelegentlich mal was machen, sondern die sind wirklich aktiv.
Das heißt, dieses Projekt ist in Life and Kicking und da wird ordentlich Code erzeugt. Wie Cross-Plattform ist das Ganze schon? Sind das alles nur Linux-Geschichten?
Am Anfang hatten wir relativ schnell auch einen Port für FreeBSD und Mac entsprechend. Als wir dann angefangen haben, diese UDP-Tunnels zu implementieren, da trennten sich dann leider die Wege. Also es gibt nicht genügend Leute, für die der Leidensdruck wirklich groß genug wäre, dass sie versuchen würden, jetzt Batman wirklich für sich auf FreeBSD und Mac OS X laufen zu lassen. Wir haben früher mit OLSR, war es uns ganz wichtig, wir dachten, wir müssen OLSR unbedingt für jedes mögliche Betriebssystem haben, also vor allem auch für Windows. Und wir haben uns damit sehr viel Ärger eingehandelt. Die Sache ist die, es gibt ja nach wie vor diese Probleme mit den WLAN-Chipsets, dass die im Ad-hoc-Modus, haben wir jetzt noch nicht angeschnitten, aber man hat einfach, da der Ad-hoc-Modus ist relativ schwierig zu implementieren, jeder denkt, der wird nur selten gebraucht, deswegen wird da wenig Aufwand reingelegt, also es muss irgendwie so ein bisschen was machen, damit es diesen Wi-Fi-Logo-Stempel irgendwie kriegt, aber das heißt, das funktioniert alles fast gar nicht, also es ist wirklich zum Haare raufen und es gibt nur...
Ist das ein Problem der Chips oder ein Problem der Treiber?
Das ist ein Problem der Treiber. Also...
Das heißt, man kriegt gar nicht den Zugriff über den Treiber auf den Stein, den man bräuchte, um alles machen zu können, was man machen muss, um Batman richtig zum Laufen zu bekommen?
Da gibt es Probleme, zum Teil liegen die in der Firmware, also du kriegst bei vielen Geräten halt eine binary-only-Firmware, die in die Karten geladen wird oder in denen installiert wird und die ist halt oft fehlerhaft, also die macht halt, der Ad-hoc-Modus ist halt relativ komplex von sich aus, der ist ähnlich komplex zu implementieren wie beispielsweise eben die Access-Point-Firmware in einem Access-Point, also viel, viel komplexer als zum Beispiel eine einfache Client-Implementierung und bei Linux war es halt bislang leider so, dass praktisch alle Programmierer, die Treiber entwickelt haben, jedes Mal das Rad von neuem erfunden haben. Das soll jetzt besser werden, also mit kernel 2622 und dem nächsten 2623 gibt es einen eigenen Wi-Fi-Stack, auf den man zurückgreifen kann. Der hieß früher D80211, der wurde von der Firma Devicecape übernommen, die haben den unter GPL gestellt und heißt jetzt M80211 oder Mac 802.11. Aber im Moment ist es so, es ist noch das Tal der Tränen, also die meisten Programmierer sind gerade dabei, ihren Treiber, den sie schon haben, jetzt kompatibel zu machen mit diesem neuen Stack. Und also gerade im Ad-hoc-Modus ist es immer noch so, das fasst man halt zuletzt an, wenn überhaupt. Und leider ist es so, die Treibersituation ist, wie gesagt, zum Haare rauf und am besten funktionieren wirklich noch diese Broadcom-Geräte, die allerdings einen Binary-only Close Source Treiber haben von der Firma Broadcom.
Das heißt, was ist jetzt so die derzeit empfohlene Hardware, wenn man jetzt selber ein Bitmann-Netz aufbauen möchte und es jetzt nicht wichtig ist, dass es auf dem Mac oder unter Windows läuft, sondern wo es jetzt eigentlich nur darum geht, dass man eine Infrastruktur baut, die dann benutzt wird? Was nennt man dann?
Entweder man nimmt ein Broadcom-basiertes Gerät, eben wie den WRT54GL von Linksys oder den Buffalo WHR54GS oder GH. Oder du nimmst eine WLAN-Karte von Atheros. Unter Linus gibt es da diesen MED-Wi-Fi-Triber. Der hat unglaublich viele Features, aber er gewinnt auch inzwischen sehr gut an Stabilität, was den Ad-hoc-Modus anbelangt. Von der Funktionsvielfalt ist der MED-Wi-Fi-Triber für die Atheros-Karten eine echte Wundertüte. Mittlerweile gibt es aber auch so viel Interesse von Leuten, dass der MED-Wi-Fi-Triber im Ad-hoc-Modus funktioniert, dass er auch wirklich inzwischen brauchbar ist.
Wir hatten vorhin auch schon nochmal nur gesprochen, das ist vielleicht jetzt auch mal ein guter Abschluss für das Thema. Sehr viel Wind hat ja auch gemacht dieses FON-Projekt, der Versuch, möglichst kostengünstig bis kostenlose Router unter die Leute zu bringen, die dann alle überall WLANs aufbauen sollen, um ebenso öffentliche Hotspots anzubieten. Ich hatte das Thema ja hier auch bei Chaosradio Express mal, ein Interview gemacht mit demjenigen, der es losgetreten hat. So richtig viel Impact scheint das Projekt dann doch nicht entwickelt zu haben. Zumindest wird derzeit nicht so viel drüber geredet. Aber die Geräte haben ganz gute Verbreitung gefunden.
Die Geräte haben gute Verbreitung gefunden, ja. Wobei die, also die Geräte, da muss man sagen, die haben von der Firma Acton, also die die Fornerer 1, oder die erste Fornerer, die da auf den Markt kam, die wurde von der Firma Acton in Taiwan hergestellt und das Gerät hat thermische Probleme. Das ist ein recht preiswertes Design, eigentlich sehr nett. Das verwendet ein Ateros-System on a Chip, also Ateros WLAN mit integriertem Prozessor. Und die Acton-Geräte, die über Hitzen eigentlich dauern. Also die meisten Leute haben da thermische Probleme. Die Geräte laufen einfach unzuverlässig, vor allem wenn es wärmer wird. Und es gibt viele Foren mit Fotos, wie Leute versuchen halt da intern das Blech, mit dem der Radioteil abgeschirmt wird, aufzubrechen. Und selbst sich ihre eigenen Kühler irgendwie drauf zu basteln. Oder das ganze Ding mit einem ausgewachsenen Prozessorlüfter zu kühlen, um da ein bisschen Stabilität reinzubekommen. An sich sind die Geräte extrem schick. Schön klein, ein bisschen größer als eine Zigaretten-Schachtel. Eigentlich super, aber wie gesagt, beim thermischen Design hat Acton ziemlich einen Mist gebaut.
Also nicht so zu empfehlen.
Nicht so zu empfehlen, außer sie sind halt extrem billig. Ein Ding ist, es gibt von einem Italiener, von Antonio Anselmi, gibt es ein Projekt, das heißt Robin, und der verwendet Batman auf dem Ateros-System. Und der Ateros-Treiber, also der MedWiFi-Treiber unter Linux, der beherrscht Multimode. Und zwar kann er gleichzeitig ad hoc sprechen und gleichzeitig ein Access Point sein. Und damit gibt es einen Traum von vielen Leuten in Erfüllung, die sich immer gedacht haben, das wäre doch eigentlich ganz cool, ein kleines Gerät zu haben, was per Mesh sich vernetzt und eben...... selber ein Access Point ist, um die ganzen Probleme, die man mit der anderen Hardware hat, die eben halt nicht ad hoc richtig reden kann, um mit denen zu sprechen. Ich kann allerdings noch nichts drüber sagen, weil ich besitze selber keinen Furnierer. Es scheint wohl zu funktionieren. Allerdings ist die Einschränkung noch, dass der ad hoc-Modus ist kein echter ad hoc-Modus, sondern der ad hoc-Demo-Modus, was eine abgespeckte Version von dem ad hoc-Modus ist. Es gibt einen ad hoc-Modus, in dem keine Beacons verschickt werden. Das Netz ist dann quasi unsichtbar für andere.
Ah ja, verstehe. Also ein Hidden Network, das man selber benutzen kann.
Genau. Was im ad hoc-Modus läuft, gibt es aber Performance-Probleme, wenn es in Konkurrenz mit anderen WLANs ist, die auf dem gleichen Kanal sind, weil die von dem anderen eben nicht gesehen werden.
Das Einfachste wäre natürlich, dass man sich einen billigen WLAN-Router nimmt, um einfach das eigene Netzwerk und Access-Point zu haben. Da steckt man dann einfach eine Büchse dran, die Batman spricht.
Oder ein Gerät, was zwei Interfaces halt von Hause aus hat. Oder man hat einen Router, wo man einfach per USB noch eine WLAN-Karte einstecken kann. Es gibt ja zum Beispiel den ASUS WL500 Premium. Der hat zweimal USB 2.0. Und da könnte man beispielsweise eben USB-WLAN-Karten einstecken. Ein Traum oder ein Wunsch von mir wäre, dass es endlich mal auch stabil funktionierende USB-WLAN-Karten und Linux gibt, die ad hoc, master und klein sprechen. Das tun sie sowieso. Aber ad hoc halt stabil. Damit könnte man recht preiswert sogenannte Super-Notes bauen. Also zum Beispiel hat Intel jetzt so ein neues Mainboard auf den Markt gebracht. Das ist so ein Mini-ITX-Board. Das ist 17 x 17 cm groß. Das kostet einschließlich einem Celeron-M-Prozessor 69 Euro beim Elektronikversender Reichelt.
Das ist nicht viel.
Das ist nicht viel und das hat 6 x USB 2.0. Da könnte man also per USB sich Antennen anstecken. Man könnte sich eine rundstrahlende Antenne bauen oder eine Richtantenne oder eine sogenannte Sektor-Antenne und die einfach über ein USB-Kabel für 2 Euro 5 Meter lang, also von einem Gerät, trennen. Das heißt, die Antennen würden sich auch nicht gegenseitig kaum stören. Weil man hat ja sonst, wenn man jetzt mehrere Antennen unmittelbar auf einem Haufen hat und da hat mehrere WLAN-Karten in einem Metallgehäuse, in einem Gerät drin, die stören sich ja gegenseitig, auch wenn sie jetzt nicht unbedingt auf dem gleichen Kanal arbeiten, was ja keinen Sinn machen würde. Da könnte man also einiges reißen. Aber leider, leider, leider, also bester Kandidat wäre eigentlich die Firma Raling. Da gibt es USB-Dongles, RT73 ist der Chipsatz da drin. Sehr gute Empfangs- und Sendeleistung. Also die eingebauten Antennen in so einem kleinen USB-Dongle sind natürlich Mist, aber wenn man da eine richtige dran macht, also ich habe das ausprobiert, hervorragende Empfangsleistung, nur der Ad hoc-Modus funktioniert ein bisschen. Aber ich habe zwei Stationen, eine ist direkt neben mir dran. Sobald ich die sehe, kann ich entferntere Stationen nicht mehr erreichen. Die sind dann plötzlich verschwunden.
Also es gibt eine ganze Menge Zeug, mit dem man noch weiter rumbasteln könnte. Und es gibt vor allem noch eine Menge Möglichkeiten, auch bei dem Batman-Projekt noch weitere Ressourcen hinzuzubringen. Sucht ihr noch irgendjemand, oder seid ihr mit Programmierern überschüttet?
Ich glaube, also noch mehr Programmierer brauchen wir nicht unbedingt.
Aber vielleicht andere Dienstleistungen, die die Szene beitragen könnten?
Interessant wäre die Sache zu forcieren, Batman Advanced, direkt an die WLAN-Hardware heranzugehen und Batman dafür zu portieren, da wird schon Arbeit gemacht. Aber da kann man auf jeden Fall noch fähige Leute brauchen. Aber mein heißester Wunsch wäre ein Treiber für USB-WLAN-Karten, beispielsweise gerade von Raling. Weil die sind absolut preiswert und qualitativ sehr gut.
Da kommt man gut dran, und das kann man auch an jeden Rechner mit dranstellen.
Genau, die Geräte gibt es in jedem Supermarkt. Die kosten, wenn man sie günstig einkauft, 15 Euro das Stück. Für eine sehr empfindliche WLAN-Karte mit 100 mW Sendeleistung ist das ein Schnippchen.
Als Letztes fällt mir gerade noch mal ein, ich wollte jetzt nicht so eine große Themenkarte aufmachen, aber ein Problem oder eine Eigenschaft dieser Freifunknetze war ja, dass man da im Prinzip, wenn man daran teilnehmen will, einfach sich eine IP-Adresse auch zuteilen lassen muss. Fällt das bei Batman eigentlich in irgendeiner Form auch noch mal in einem anderen Bereich, dass diese Netze dynamischer konfigurieren lassen können?
Bei Batman Advanced, also was eben auf der Basis einer MAC-Adresse von einer WLAN-Karte basiert, entfällt das sowieso.
Klar, weil dann ist man einfach in einem Netz und dann kann man sich einen DHCP-Server hinstellen und es geht.
Genau, einen DHCP-Server, die kann man schon überall erreichen.
Bei dem normalen Batman?
Bei dem normalen Batman, dieses Robin, also dieses Projekte, das Forneo-Projekt mit dem Batman drin, die haben sich IP-Autokonfiguration ausgedacht. Also man kann wirklich die Geräte nehmen, die Firmware einspielen und das ist es.
Lecker! Ich sehe schon, es ist eine ganze Menge passiert. Wem das jetzt alles zu technisch war, aber vielleicht trotzdem Interesse hat, in das Thema noch mal tiefer einzutauchen, so dass überhaupt bis hier mitgehört hat, dem kann ich noch mal das Buch empfehlen von Elektra. Mesh-Drahtlose Ad-Hoc-Netze erschienen bei Open Source Press. Kostet?
1990.
1990, ist also billig. Und ich glaube auch gerade zu Batman, das Kapitel gibt es auch als Schnupper-Kapitel im Internet unter opensourcepress.de.
Der Verlag hat sich entschieden, also als Leseprobe das gesamte Batman-Kapitel zu veröffentlichen.
Tolle Sache. Aber es gibt noch viele andere interessante Kapitel über die Karten, über die Chipsätze, über Antennen im Allgemeinen und natürlich auch über OLSR und die ganze Geschichte und Mesh-Routing insbesondere.
Die Idee war, Leute, die sich mit Freifunk beschäftigen wollen und selber vielleicht so einen Netzwerk aufbauen wollen, die einfach damit glücklich zu machen. Da stehen halt so Sachen drin, wo man am Anfang nicht draufkommt. Also ich wäre ganz froh gewesen, wenn ich vor ein paar Jahren so ein Buch gehabt hätte, um zum Beispiel zu wissen, dass man mit der WLAN-Karte überhaupt nicht anfangen muss. Also das wird nie was. Also diesen ganzen Ärger, den ich selber damit hatte, die viele Erfahrungen stecken da halt drin. Bis jetzt habe ich eigentlich nur gutes Feedback für das Buch bekommen.
Okay, super. Haben wir alles erwähnt, was wir erwähnen wollten?
Ich weiß nicht, du hattest da eine Liste angelegt.
Ich habe meine Listen hier abgearbeitet und da steht jetzt eigentlich nichts mehr weiter drauf. Insofern würde ich sagen, vielen Dank, Elektra.
Ich danke dir.
Was haben wir denn zusammenbekommen? 1 Stunde und 20 Minuten, das ist ja ganz ordentlich.
Schon wieder viel zu lange.
Ach, nö. Das Feedback, was ich bisher immer bekommen habe, ist immer so lange reden, bis man auch wirklich mal alles abgedeckt hat, weil wer Podcasts hört, hat sowieso Zeit. Ich hoffe, damit liege ich richtig. Wenn ich damit falsch liege, dann schickt ihr euer Feedback, wie immer, an Chaosradio at ccc.de. Dort wird es auch gelesen und gehört. Und ich würde mich freuen, wenn wir Feedback bekommen, nicht nur auf diese Sendung, auch generell, wie es weitergehen soll mit Chaosradio Express. Ich werde mich auf jeden Fall in der nächsten Zeit bemühen, weitere Themenkarten aufzurufen und habe auch schon eine längere Liste zusammen. Ich bedanke mich nochmal bei dir, Elektra. Und wir alle hören uns bald wieder bei Chaosradio Express. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove. Bis zum nächsten Mal.